did you shed a tear during the series
finale of jesse
if so dry those eyes because we are
going back in time to see what would
have happened if the series kept on
going
it's been a long time since you saw the
final episode or if you struggle to see
through the tears
we'll quickly get you up to speed
christina ross
finally went home to new york city just
in time to make jessie's dreams of
stardom come true by casting her in
tournament of scepters
christina opened a metaphorical door for
jessie and tony went to la in order to
open
more literal ones then we have bunked
which isn't part of the main jessie
storyline but still featured some of our
favorite characters
we learned that emma got a job modeling
in milan zuri earned an internship at
her dad's film studio
and ravi received an academic fellowship
to the surprise of no one
while luke wasn't a cast member on bunkt
he did make an appearance announcing
that he'd aced summer school
okay now that you're up to speed and i'm
out of breath let's look at what would
have happened spin-off aside
what would have happened if jesse
continued on for just a few more seasons
and maybe even experienced a small time
skip
bunked made it seem like the ross family
would take off in different directions
but we know they can't stay away from
each other for too long or jessie for
that matter
zuri took a job working for her dad's
film studio but you know this clever and
creative gal
isn't going to limit herself to fetching
coffee and filling out paperwork
zuri may have outgrown some of her
imaginary friends like chubby the bear
and millie the mermaid
the latter of whom perished tragically
on the business end of a swordfish
but her creativity is still raring to go
and combined with her go-getter attitude
could make her a showrunner for a kid's
television show
maybe zuri could even go back and save
nilly from her fishy fate
or make her a star or a c star as the
case may be
her take charge attitude would come in
handy and for some reason
we don't think she'd have a problem
giving orders on set sometimes a little
bit of bossiness is
exactly what's needed especially if she
already had some experience with her
crew
emma's always been the fashionista of
the ross family and while we love the
idea of her repping her mom's style in
milan
how long can she really stay away from
her family
she'd definitely start missing them
after she's away long enough to forget
how crazy they drive her
zuri once accused emma of lacking
imagination and this could be the
perfect chance for big sis to prove her
wrong
by taking over the wardrobe department
of her show a stylish job that can
double as an i told you so moment
that's what we call a win-win it's hard
to properly accessorize seashells but we
know emma would be up to the task
now who needs some more imagination not
only does emma know fashion but she's an
expert at forging connections and could
help smooth things over with the cast
and crew if zuri finds herself clashing
with them
so few geniuses are appreciated in their
own time ravi may not enjoy the
spotlight as much as his siblings
but we know how much zuri likes having
him around
to play pranks on it's possible his
scholarly pursuits won't quite cover the
bills but his sisters can hook him up
with a job as an animal wrangler and
script supervisor on the show
after all why let all that experience
with a giant asian monitor lizard go to
waste
with ravi around zuri's show could be
entertaining and educational
and what's better than that although
he's a qualified animal expert
ravi might also push to get his
celebrity crush selena gomez on as a
special guest
if zuri let that happen ravi and zuri
are two peas in a pod
until something goes wrong and she needs
ravi to take the blame
will an older zuri pull more
sophisticated pranks or simply see what
kind of havoc lizards can unleash
on set yeah probably that one
sadly actor cameron boyce who played the
role of luke ross passed away
just after jesse finished filming it
would be wrong to have someone else take
over the part he spent so much time
perfecting
and not that many people could match his
dancing moves if the show continued
luke could have joined an international
dance troupe living his dream and
showing off his skills
all over the world plus there's one big
bonus to luke going away overseas
he'll be a lot harder for the overly
obsessive connie thompson to track down
setting a world record is usually a good
thing but not when it comes to racking
up the most restraining orders
now it's time for the star of the show
jessie prescott herself
well who else could possibly fill the
fins of millie the mermaid
living in la isn't cheap alles and
jessie may have learned by this point
a steady gig like zuri's show could be
the perfect fit and a ton of fun behind
the scenes with some of her favorite
people
plus how many actors have experience
with a seven foot long lizard on their
resume
what better way for millie to get over
her dislike of jessie than to have her
portray her on tv
there could even be some fun new
characters added to the cast like
millie's centaur husband and their
three little fish children cheddar
extreme cheddar and cool ranch
hey mythological creature dna is really
complicated
emma would finally get a chance to
thoroughly fix jesse's fashion sense
at least while the cameras are rolling
and jessie wouldn't be the nanny anymore
but she could still stop zuri from
picking on ravi too much
what do you think would have been the
next step for the jessie cast if the
series had continued
share your ideas with us and your fellow
fans in the comment section below
and make sure to click on the subscribe
button for more new videos from us here
at the things
bye for now
[Music]
you